whoa our solar system is plunging into
chaos
better hang on tight the planets are
getting knocked out of orbit
what could Kickstart this epic chain of
events
[Music]
how would this impact each and every
planet
and how could it possibly make earth
even more hospitable to life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the planets were knocked off
course
the Solar System's planets have remained
in stable orbit around the Sun for
billions of years and they'll likely
remain so for at least another 100 000
years
thanks Newton's first law of motion
but the forces that disturb this balance
could already be underway
like a giant Rogue star not bound to any
Galaxy or a Wandering black hole
and bad news for us our universe is
littered with agents of chaos ready to
disrupt our planetary neighborhood at
any moment
Interstellar chaos Reigns in outer space
but back on Earth it's not too different
we're dealing with a triple threat to
our Public Health this season the flu
RSV and a Resurgence of covet 19. yeah
almost three years later and covet is
still here but you're not helpless in
this fight and if you didn't know
there's a new booster available and it's
completely free you just have to be two
months out from your first vac shot or
your last booster and this shot is the
first to address the covet variant
people are Contracting now look variants
of this virus will continue to evolve
and pop up and that can't be stopped but
the booster shots are our best chance to
fight off these threats now even if you
feel like you're not at risk there are
vulnerable groups who can't take chances
with their health so don't put yourself
or the people around you in Danger let's
fight this virus together and keep our
planet on course
it would all start with Neptune
Neptune doesn't need to be knocked out
of alignment much for bad things to
happen
if this icy Giant's orbit Changed by
even 0.1 percent it could trigger a
series of events that really mess things
up
with Neptune's orbit in flux it would
begin to influence the orbits of its
neighbors and sooner or later each
planet's Disturbed orbit would unleash
total chaos in our solar system
at first you wouldn't see much from
Earth
only astronomers would notice the
slightest changes in planetary orbits
they'd be the first to know that
something really wrong was about to
happen
these disturbances would build up and
eventually they'd reached a Tipping
Point
Neptune's changed orbit would affect
Uranus these two ice giants would come
dangerously close to each other and then
they'd pluck Saturn out of its orbit
this Trio could be ejected out of the
solar system entirely and none of the
other planets would be safe from this
ensuing Cosmic pandemonium because as
Neptune Uranus and Saturn were on the
way out of our planetary neighborhood
they'd shoved the biggest planet in the
solar system off its rails
Jupiter
instead of revolving around the Sun in
an almost perfect circle Jupiter would
now have an erratic elliptical orbit
sometimes it would be closer and other
times it would be further away
and this would impact Earth's orbit as
well one peculiar effect would be a new
kind of global warming
our new orbit would result in the
coldest parts of the planet reaching
more pleasant temperatures
as this Celestial domino effect
continued Venus's orbit would change too
if it started to spend more time further
away from the Sun would there be a
chance that it could cool down enough to
become habitable
well not exactly Venus's scorching
temperatures run as high as
462 degrees Celsius and that's not just
because of its proximity to the sun it's
due to its runaway greenhouse effect
Venus's thick atmosphere already
reflects about 75 percent of any
incoming radiation
small shift in its position wouldn't be
enough to offset the greenhouse gases
that keep it sweltering
on the other hand Mercury wouldn't be
let off the hook so easily a new orbit
could lead to a close encounter with the
sun and that could eject it from the
solar system as well
all these planets being forced into new
trajectories could also lead to
something a little more dramatic Than
Just Close Encounters they could collide
yeah Venus and Mercury could slam into
each other and form a new planet
well brace yourself for the possibility
of a full-on collision with Mars if that
happened it would be bad news for you
if Mars crashed into Earth well there
would be no way you'd survive this
impact and you'd have nowhere to run
from this doomsday scenario
could you be worried about any of this
well most flybys close to our solar
system like a rogue star probably
wouldn't lead to such a dramatic
destabilization
anything we might consider to be a
threat only occurs once every 100
billion years
though now that I think about it I
wonder what it would be like if a black
hole with the power to eat a rogue star
appeared in our solar system out of
nowhere
well that's a story
for another
what if